in sunset overdrive you yes you are the  hero customize your character be who you  want to be traverse the open world with  speed strategy and style using an  arsenal of unconventional weapons and  special abilities to save sunset city  now in this demo to the games factions  have overrun the local amusement park  and our mission is to fight our way to  the roller coaster on the far side let's  go  now it's not just about the campaign  we've also got a big a player experience  called chaos squad on dedicated servers  powered by Xbox Live eight friends  cooperatively earn loot and save sunset  City so whether you're playing solo or  with friends beat a hero you want to be  in sunset overdrive starting October  28th exclusively on Xbox one thank you